it was a ceremony on the south lawn of
the white house to mark an historic
confirmation that had been centuries in
the making it has taken 232
years and 115
prior appointments
for a black woman
to be selected to serve on the supreme
court of the united states
but we've made it
we've made it all of us
all of us
and this nomination is confirmed
judge kataji brown jackson was confirmed
to the nation's highest court on
thursday in the u.s senate the
significance of the moment was not lost
on kamala harris who made history as
america's first female and woman of
color vice president
you will inspire
generations
of leaders
and they will see
for the first time
four women sitting on that court at one
time
katanji brown jackson's confirmation is
victory for president joe biden whose
approval ratings are in need of a boost
including among black voters who helped
elect him to the white house
but on friday it wasn't his political
future that biden was focused on but
instead the women this moment could
inspire this is going to let so much
shine sun shine on so many
young women
so many young black women so many
minorities
that it's real i look back and see this
is a moment of real change
in american history
jackson says that as the child of
parents who attended racially segregated
schools america is on the right path
in my family it took just one generation
to go from segregation to the supreme
court of the united states
when jackson is sworn in later this year
for the first time white men will no
longer make up a majority on the court
for the first time the u.s supreme court
will look
more like the america it serves
a goal of president biden's when he took
office
kimberly hellcat al jazeera the white
house